nous sommes ici dans le temple dédié à
kanti au centre-ville de saint-pierre un
sanctuaire où la communauté chinoise de
la réunion installé depuis quatre
générations vient se ressourcer une
culture chinoise que marie jeanne et les
membres de l'association quantique
s'efforce de transmettre à travers un
enseignement et des pratiques rituelles
marie-jeanne notre guide nous explique
cette philosophie positive qui a guidé
grand nombre de fidèles alors vous êtes
dans le temple qui est dédié à paris
vous savez donc au point click est
représenté par cette nature on entre
alors à côté de plantes y avait
plusieurs de ses thèmes ici l'autel du
dieu de la fortune fractionne derrière
vous avez le dieu taoïste parlent tous
de l'autre côté vous avez un sage
taoïste
qui est le doux et vous avez ici l'autel
des ancêtres
qui est très important dans les
pratiques disons chinoise est ce qu'il
ya une telle que fréquenter que d'autres
l'ont généralement quand les gens
viennent ici ça presse sur la vérité et
à raconter
or le poids des différents hôtels sauf
si en hiver que en huit mois le culte
des ancêtres
on s'attarde davantage à l'autel des
ancêtres c'est très important l'autel
des ancêtres pour les chinois ça remonte
bien avant confie le social je ne suis
sûr qu'ils le physicien qui a dix ont
dicté un peu les riques régler à essence
à savoir que pour le consensus qui était
très importante c'était les relations
les relations établies dans la société
et en premier rôle dans la famille c'est
à dire un certain nombre
les relations entre le père et le fils
et ensuite pour devenir dans la société
la relation entre le prince et sur ce
sujet et les relations entre les
différentes de personnes le frère le
frère aîné le faire tab est donc en
prenant les poux et son épouse
et vous avez ici le disons le bon alors
qu'on utilise uniquement pour commencer
la cérémonie
que pour le culte on va faire pour son
anniversaire
par ce 24 juillet date anniversaire de
kanti toutes les générations des chinois
de notre île se sont retrouvés au temple
de saint pierre pour célébrer ce culte
philosophiques et religieux un rituel de
tradition des offrandes et des prières
ont dominé cette cérémonie qui a permis
de rappeler lui principe voué à county
fidélité sincérité droiture courage
probité grandeur bonheur et honnêteté
quelle est l'histoire qu'il est rattaché
à ce qu'à son âge alors c'est un
personnage historique qui a de plus de
la période 150 à 220
de notre ère et qui était un valeureux
de son client il s'applique pas nu
c'était un valeureux guerriers et ce
qu'ils font ils de quoi nous il avait
demandé valeur physique de mon force
physique d'une force morale
légendaires telles que celles utilisées
pour défendre là pour défendre la patrie
l'empereur parce qu'il a été fidèle à
son ampleur est ce qu'il faut dire de
quoi nu c'est que il était imprégné
de confiance du confucianisme donc et il
a comme guerrier il a voulu surtout
défendre la patrie et l'empereur mais
malheureusement il ne va pas réussir
dans son entreprise puisque la chine
sera divisé en trois provinces
juste à la mort de quoi ce qu'il faut
dire aussi c'est qu'il a été tué par
l'un des dissidents de l'empereur
regardez et ce n'est que par la suite
qui va passer en quelque sorte dans la
légende à travers lé théâtre ambulant
les chansons les romans et pour il sera
élevé au rang de dieu le dieu non pas de
dieu comme on l'entend
dans certaines religions mais disons
comme un sage je me dis c'est une
divinité et il va si vous voulez c'est
un empereur du 16e siècle qui va
l'élever assurant parce que lui attribue
des pouvoirs de protection
à partir de cette période il ya eu pas
mal de temples sont élevés en chine
à l'honneur de coin titre à savoir qu'il
a eu quand même une période de
l'histoire de la fille le maoïsme quand
même on a voulu éradiquer toutes les
pratiques religieuses en chine et tout
donc à savoir à la période du maoïsme
des plans qui ont été détruits donc ce
qui fait que en chine à l'heure actuelle
il y avait longtemps que sont les
diables rouges et c'est surtout dans la
diaspora chinoise qui repose les temples
de coin est partout on va où il ya une
communauté chinoise il ya un temple
élevé à la mémoire des points qui tenait
la réunion il y en a combien à la
réunion il y en a deux un donné un chez
nous à savoir que ce temple outre si
vous voulez les pratiques qu'on peuvent
y faire qui sont des pratiques surtout
disons de culte aux ancêtres
c'est ça une valeur disons pour
rassembler les gens de la communauté
historique d'ailleurs je pense que on y
attache beaucoup d'importance parce que
il représente beaucoup de valeurs
morales
comme la fidélité
la justice le courage qui sont des
forces
essentielles et qui ont dû beaucoup
compté pour nos parents qui ont honte
immigrés et je pense qu'ils ont eu
besoin de se référer un personnage aussi
son coin parce qu'elle beaucoup de
visiteurs à ce qu'il ya pas mal de gens
si oui je pense que moi même j'ai eu
l'occasion de féliciter le temple a pas
mal de champs qui le souhaitaient de la
porte est ouverte donc ils peuvent venir
voir non s'ils veulent une visite plus
organisée bon il faut qu'ils en fassent
la demande au président de l'association
qui gère le temple
ici c'est le bouddhisme
c'est en pratique le bouddhisme
et c'est sedan est dédié à une ds un
body simple à
poigne
lui c'est le nombre d'atr
de ce temple on l'appelait le mauricien
parce qu'il venait de maurice parce que
vous savez le fait suivant les rayons
principe est toujours à maurice avant de
venir s'établir à la réunion et donc et
ce sont des personnes qui souvent ont
beaucoup fréquenté je tente il ya quand
même ce côté paisible si oui voilà
beaucoup plus s'en sortait yeux est de
toucher la méditation aussi donc il faut
un calme il faut on commet
une atmosphère qui traite proche de bord
de la mer en chine qui a le bruit de la
mer tout ça qui aident à à une
concentration et une méditation
et à la rivière c'est elle qui prépare
des temps délabre qui sont commandés
avec le nom des personnes au fait des
offrandes à point des candélabres qui
ont illuminé le temple taoïste dans sa
tenue et d'anniversaires ou 2500
personnes ont été réunies parmi elles
les nouveaux bacheliers de la dernière
génération qui ont reçu les
félicitations de leurs aînés ce
rassemblement a permis aussi de
resserrer les liens d'unité et de
coutumes d'une communauté chinoise qui a
parfaitement réussi son intégration
pour marie jeanne dont le dévouement est
particulièrement apprécié la
transmission des valeurs sera encore
pendant longtemps une de ses
préoccupations premières au sein de
l'association mais aussi de sa propre
famille qu'elle voit s'agrandir
sinon bon ben j'ai une vie
professionnelle et vie familiale
et des loisirs et des loisirs il à
part un petit peu de grossir alors mes
loisirs
autrefois c'était le basket
le produit
pas mal de temps et maintenant j'ai
raccrocher les baskets
il ya très peu de temps et donc
maintenant je m'occupe plus tôt 2 et
petits enfants
je voudrais leur tendance à clé beaucoup
plus de temps que je leur consacre je
n'avais pas là j'en ai deux
petite fille de 8 ans et un petit fils
de 200 et 2 exactement
10on de formation je suis enseignant et
je vais
j'étais sûr pour se détacher au centre
local de documentation pédagogique
alors d'ici un peu plus d'une semaine je
serai à la retraite
et ma foi je pense que ça va être un
changement d'orientation de bas dans ma
vie et
je pense que
j'aurai je pourrai me consacrer à des
choses que je
souhaitais le fait qu'ils n'avaient pas
une occasion de le faire il sait pas
être passéiste mais le passé conditionne
le présent et tout cela conditionne
l'avenir donc si vous voulez un
cheminement art est respecté et on ne
peut pas je pense occulté
ce jeune on ne peut pas ignorer le
cheminement combat à voir sans être
passéiste et sans je pense qu'il faut
vivre pleinement l'événement mais en
sachant très bien par exemple que nos
parents étaient est ce que nous sommes
et bien sûr ça ça va être la condition
de demain
voilà en train une succession de pièces
et c'est à ce city bon ben
c'est vrai que la lumière n'éclaire que
celui qui la porte et l'expérience
personnelle et est une expérience
personnelle c'est à dire on peut pas non
plus vivre de l'expérience les autres et
chacun doit avoir son propre gagnante
dans la vie
m